our hearts are in a very
very sidetracked and cluttered
with play and just and they are
not taking the Quran and its
narrative seriously. Because
even if a person were to reject
the conclusions that the Quran
gives us. It doesn't mean that
a person would take the matters
that the Quran deals with
lightly. The Quran deals with
what matters. The most
important matters that could
that could have any bearing on
any human being's life. Why do
I exist? Who is my creator?
There is a resurrection. What
is after death? What is death
itself? What is the nature of
the soul? These kinds of things
that the Quran speaks about.
Where did we come from? Where
are we going? What awaits us
after death? The descriptions
of Allah. So this is not
something to be taken lightly.
This is not this is not
something that should be joked
about or something that any
person who has any respect or
reverence for Allah would take
in any kind of joking matter.
And so,
We see that there is a general
lack of respect for these
topics even if they disagree
with the with the conclusions
that the Quran draws. The the
Quran tells us Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala tells us of his
descriptions. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala tells us of the
nature of our existence. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us of
all of these things. These are
the most important things to
any of us. Tells us our
descriptions. Who we are in the
scheme of things. This is
there's nothing more important
than this. Ever. Never. There
no topic more important to any
human being than this whether
they know it or not. And so the
fact that
antago
nist of the prophet would
take these topics lightly and
would take these topics with
with mockery and would make a
mockery of the conclusions
drawn by the Quran tells us
that they don't take these
topics very seriously anyways.
And this is why we see some
very strange conclusions that
they come to. For instance, one
of their conclusions is, how
could be resurrected? How could
we be resurrected after we die?
This
is the question of a
person who has not has not
taken this matter seriously
enough to follow through with
the logical steps that would
lead to this conclusion. If a
person takes creation seriously
and honestly acknowledges that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
created all things from
nothing, then, this train of
thought must deliver them to a
station of belief in,
concurrent, existence.
Subsequent resurrection But
they stopped there because all
they cared about was this
world. So, we just care about
this world and what it has for
us. Anything after that, it's
not really a big deal. So, they
stopped there. Likewise,
believe in Allah Subhanahu wa
ta'ala. If you truly believe in
Allah there's no possible way
to believe in any other
creators along with Allah. As
this chapter will address. And
if that's the case, then
there's only one creator and
this one creator's descriptions
must be one, two, three, four,
five, you know, all of the
descriptions that we have in
the Quran and Sunnah. These
descriptions were not present
with the
Arabs, most of them. A lot of
them for instance, a good
example of this
one of the most common names
today of all time is the name
Abdul Rahman, right? And this
is one of the most profound
names of Allah, Al Rahman. They
acknowledge the name Allah but
they did not acknowledge Al
Rahman.
Why didn't pagan Arabs affirm
the name Al Rahman for Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The answer is
They could not conceptualize
anyone with that amount of
mercy, not even Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. So, the name fell
into disuse and when we when we
research this name, Abdul
Rahman, we find or Al Rahman,
we find that only two or three
instances in all of the
Jehiliah. Does anybody have the
name? Abdul Rahman. Most people
would have the name Abdullah.
That was a common name. Abdul
Rahman. Almost heard of. Why?
Because this name articulates
immense unfathomable amounts of
mercy and they believe that
this was not even a description
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
himself. Not even he has that
much mercy. and so on and so
forth. The conclusions that
they had arrived at with
regards to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and his names and
attributes and his abilities
and so forth. They were not,
they were not in line with the
rudimentary beliefs that they
held. and so The reason for
this is that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said their hearts are
just in constant play, in
constant seek of enjoyment.
that's it. Constant in constant
pursuit of happiness, whatever
that is. Right? We have this
idea. Going around. It's even
written in the Constitution
that every man has thee,
god-given right to the to
freedom and liberty in the
pursuit of happiness. What does
that even mean? The pursuit of
happiness. That's not a very
good thing to to pursue all the
time. In all cases. If a person
is dictated by the pursuit of
happiness in making his
decisions, a lot of his
decisions will be very bad
decisions.
It would be more correct if it
was the pursuit of
meaningfulness and in pursuit
of meaningfulness, a person may
find happiness. Yes. But
happiness in itself is a goal.
This is not necessarily a good
goal. If we all had this goal,
we would be very terrible
people. We would we would do
terrible things in order to
secure our own happiness.
Rather, we pursue that which is
meaningful. Even if it doesn't
make us happy. and we
relinquish the pursuit of
things that are not meaningful
even if they may make us happy.
This is a yardstick that even
many Muslims today have come to
misunderstand. and this is
where a lot of these ideas come
from that we hear people
talking about some of these you
know some of these a lot of
these
you know, very airhead kind of
self-absorbed celebrities, you
know, whatever makes you happy,
you know, as long as you're not
hurting anyone else and it
makes you happy, then, go ahead
and do it. I mean, this is a
terrible metric system to use
in justifying good and evil.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
and they whisper to each other
those who have disbelieved and
are oppressive in their
accusations with regards to the
prophet is this not merely a
man as you all are men? A human
being as you all are humans?
The answer is yes. But the fact
that he is human does not at
all does not at all contradict
or
is not at all mutually
exclusive with prophethood. All
prophets are are men, are human
beings, our prophets. He says,
they all say to each other as
well, are you allowing
yourselves to fall under the
spell of magic even though you
can clearly see it as such? If
they could clearly see it was
such, they would not fall under
its spell. It was really magic
and they have examples of
magicians. Magicians, Yanni,
the prophet when he was asked
in about magicians and
soothsayers, he said, they're
nothing. Don't worry about
them. Don't preoccupy yourself
with them.
and that is the position that
they held in Jehili as well.
They were considered you know,
more entertainers than anything
else and a last resort than
anything else. They weren't
considered anything serious.
Poets were much more renowned
than magicians or fortune
tellers were. They were
considered most of them as
being hacks and shams which
they are. And they were
considered to have lowly lives.
and so, being that they have
examples of magic and examples
of spells and magicians and the
the the the limits, the
limitations on their abilities,
they know very well that this
is nothing magic. It says,
nothing to do with magic. In
any way, while Allah
responds to this saying, the
prophets all say and including
the messenger Muhammad my lord
knows what is said in the
heavens and in the earth and he
is the all hearing, all
knowing.
[Silence]
and it does not come to him
from Allah. They also claim
that he is a poet If we examine
these claims here We see that
these claims are very
contradicting They are
describing him with thee.
Greatest of intellectual feats,
and they are simultaneously
describing him with thee. With
mental deficiency. If a person
goes to sleep and is plagued
with nightmares and
hallucinations, this
articulates mental illness. And
if a person is a master poet,
this articulates extreme
intelligence. How can the both
of these be his description.
How is that possible? Either a
person is mad or a person is
sane. They can't be both at the
same time. Either a person is
intelligent or they are
unintelligent. Either they are
articulate or they are
inarticulate. They can't be
both simultaneously to fit, to
fit the person's mood. But this
is a pattern that we're
going to see recurring
throughout this debate
contradiction contradiction. We
see that the Quran contains
none. And his antagonist
platform and foundation is made
of a house of cards, of
contradiction. One minute they
say this, the next minute they
say this, and they don't
believe any of this. This is
just any way to reject the
truth. In any way that I can.
Reject the truth with the most,
outrageous insult or reject the
truth with the most benign of
subjects he's just a man
you. Nobody said I wasn't.
Nobody said the prophet wasn't
a man. No one, noone said that
he was superhuman. That he is
not subject to what humans are
subject to. No one said that.
That's not a claim that was
made. And that is what we refer
to in debate as a strawman.
What is a strawman? A strawman
in debate is when you paint a
picture of a non-existent enemy
and then you proceed to attack
that enemy that doesn't exist,
right? So, they'll say for
instance, he's just a man.
Okay? He's just a man and then
they start to come up with all
these things about this man and
then they start to attack this
person that doesn't even exist.
If I were to come up with now
some kind of outlandish idea of
some problem that's going on
but it's not really going on.
It's just in my mind. And then
I start to give a bunch of
speeches and talks and lectures
about this issue that doesn't
exist. What would we consider
this? A waste of time at at
most. And madness at least. A a
waste of time at least. And
madness at most.
Paranoia. And so this idea that
he is just a man is not to
respond to anything because
nothing more was claimed. He
was told many times through the
Quran Say, I am merely a man as
you all are men. Revelation
comes to me. That's the
difference. And with revelation
comes a number of a number of
conditions. A number of
criteria a set of criteria that
must come with revelation such
as honesty and good character
and strength of mind and
strength of character etcetera.
These are all conditions to
being a prophet, being a
messenger, which we will
discuss those conditions
inshallah. They say this is
something that he sees in his
sleep Then, they say, no, it's
actually something that he
comes up with while he's awake.
No, actually, he's a poet. No,
actually, he's insane. No,
actually, he's very
intelligent. Actually, he
doesn't know how to read or
write. Actually, he does know
how to read and write. Which
one is it? The prophet never
came with these claims. And
this is a good way to see
through the claims of a person
when they start to contradict
themselves. An example of this,
most people I won't say all but
most people that come as
charlatans selling snake oil,
they start their career, with
claiming that they are a saint
or claiming that they are a
good person or a reviver and
then later they'll say, no, I'm
actually the Mehdi. No,
actually a prophet. No,
actually a messenger. No,
actually and so on and so
forth. Till they reach
divinity. It changes. Right?
This is not the case of the
prophet. It was one statement
of truth, I am a messenger from
Allah and it stayed that way
until he breathed his last
breath. It never changed. It
never went above that. It never
went below that. It was always
that. and that is very very
very very revealing with
regards to the veracity of his
message because a person who
wants, if we were to discuss
now for instance, many people,
if you ask them about the
prophet they'll say, many
people meaning non Muslims the
claim is that he was not a
prophet. Well, if he wasn't a
prophet, why did he claim to be
a prophet? Let's about that.
Why would a person claim to be
a prophet? What is the end game
of a person who claims to be a
prophet? Obviously, it's to
control people, right? That's
the whole reason you would, a
person would claim falsely to
be a prophet or a messenger.
They want to control people.
Think cult, cult leaders,
right? That's a kind of false
prophet. even the greatest or
we should say loneliest example
of a false prophet would be
a false messiah that will come
at the end of time, the
greatest why does he claim to
be a prophet? Why does he later
claim to be? Later claims to be
Allah himself. Why is this?
Two, consolidate, control over
other people. To be special, to
control what people to
control what people dislike, to
control people's reverence of
him. Two, gain worldly funds to
get rich We have modern-day
examples of this. Have we heard
of Scientology before?
Scientology. A lot of a lot of
Hollywood actors and so forth
are scientologists. It's a
cult. and it was conceived by a
man
El Ron Hubbard Now, this man,
if we look into his history, we
see just a year before he
claimed to be a messenger and
come up with this new religion,
he said to his friends, you
know what the best way to
become a millionaire is? To
pretend you're a prophet
and a year later, he came up
with Scientology. That's a true
story. Why not? Why else would
you want to claim to be a
prophet and subject yourself to
people's ridicule and anger and
so if we look at the prophet
life, a person who first claims
this is his desire, his desire
is to gain control over people
Would they ever be satisfied?
Would they ever be satisfied
with just being a prophet? No,
it's going to keep the more
control they get, the more
hungry they're going to get.
So, it jumps from a saint to a
prophet to the Mehdi to the
prophet, to the messenger, to
part of divinity, to the son of
god, to all these things that
people come up with. It doesn't
stay in one place. It's it
shifts as this person desires
more and more power over people
but when we look at the prophet
life, nothing in his 40 years
prior to being a prophet
articulates that he was in any
way greedy or narcissistic or
megalomaniac or anything like
this. Nothing would articulate
that. and then when he was a
prophet, he remained as such
for 23 consecutive years. That
didn't at all stray or veer
from that meaning. So, this
articulates to us what
consistency.
That consistency is only found
in the touch of god, in the
touch of Allah, subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Human beings are are
fundamentally inconsistent
creatures. Human beings are
fundamentally contradicting.
Even the most brilliant human
beings. Even those who are upon
the Quran and Sunnah and
scholars, you will find that
they will change their
opinions, not on fundamental
issues, but they will change
their opinions of each day as
they grow. Sheikh Al Islam
Allah wrote a book on Hajj, an
entire book and then when he
went to Hajj, he came back and
erase that book and rewrote it.
Because his experience led him
to a whole different realm of
applying the the rulings on pen
and paper that need to be
applied to people in that
environment. This is the human
nature. There's nothing wrong
with it. And as long as that
change is based on evidence,
there's nothing wrong with
that. That's the, that's the,
that's the sign and the harmon,
hallmark a sharp mind that it
continues to change with the
evidence but to change on
fundamental issues, no. That
means you didn't learn the
proper thing in the first
place, right? We will continue
this inshallah tomorrow.